diamond versus hydraulic press wait for
it three
two one right now
you're getting a rush of dopamine can
you feel it
it's the chemical of anticipation
because you're expecting a reward you
want to see what happens to the diamond
don't worry i'm going to show you what
happens to the diamond in a bit
but first let's go back to that feeling
because isn't that the reason why you
waste hours scrolling through tick-tock
you cannot stay focused for long periods
of time and you lack the motivation to
work on the challenging things that
would actually really fulfill you
because dopamine tells you
just one more
and that's where the idea of dopamine
detoxing comes in a popular trend where
you cut out the fun stuff that spikes
your dopamine and supposedly it resets
your brain and you become a productivity
machine but is it really effective or
just another fad
i decided to test it out myself for
seven days and also took a brain scan
before
and after it to see how it would affect
my brain and the results were surprising
that's remarkable you can't do that in
seven days
the rules are simple no media
consumption which means no podcasts no
youtube videos no netflix
books are allowed no junk food or sugar
and no flippy floppy eater bing bong and
so
it started it's day one just woke up i
gotta check my phone
i'm gonna put this phone away in my
closet so during this dopamine fast i
also want to get back to
my ideal daily routine starts off with 7
30 getting up and immediately making my
bed
then filling up my bottle and drinking a
liter of water while
meditating outside in the sun get that
vitamin d early on
next up i should
no journal i'm gonna journal 20 minutes
or so and then
9 a.m is when i sit down and get to work
that would be the case if
i hadn't snooze for 45 minutes damn it
before starting the fast i had a really
hard time focusing because of all the
input i was taking in
but how had it affected my brain so
getting the
brain scan my brain high on dopamine
before the seven day detox
this 13 000 brain scanner gives you
insights into your ability to focus
anxiety levels how well you process
information and just in general if you
have a brain by measuring your brain's
activity
while putting you through different
tests seven mistakes that high
last time it was red everywhere right
we'll see what it's like after the week
so right now i've done my most important
work that's when i have my first meal at
3 pm roughly a healthy smoothie the
thing is i actually like doing house
chores cleaning my room doing laundry
that was way too much but without
listening to any podcast it just feels
like a chore look at him what are you
doing you're looking at me
it's getting dopamine but what if
there's more to our phone addictions
than just dopamine i think the main
reason why
i'm always so pulled towards having
headphones in my ears at all times
whenever i'm not working
it's just that sense that you're not
alone you're watching a video and it
feels like you are there with the people
and
you know them super well but they have
no clue who you are
which is called parasocial relationships
it's an actual thing
it's a weak form of connection but it is
one being a content creator
or an entrepreneur in the early stages
it's very lonely and i notice how
cutting all of that out really brings
forward this feeling of
loneliness just sitting in your room in
absolute silence
doesn't feel good 5 p.m
second and last meal of the day eggs
broccoli and ground beef
i eat the same thing every day super
easy for me i think this is one of the
most
challenging times not to use your phone
when you're eating now it's just sitting
here and eating
it's almost 9 p.m now that's when i
usually stop working i got
everything done that i wanted to get
done which is awesome that's doesn't
happen every day cause i always put too
much on my plate it's 10 30 p.m now
this is the time where i usually pop in
a podcast and always fall asleep
listening to a podcast i don't know if i
can sleep without it i've been
struggling with sleep for years we'll
see how it affects my sleep
and then on day two of the fast it
finally happened
i had transcended my pathetic self
my presence was like butter cutting
through a hot knife
and i finally saw the light
[Music]
i slept pretty well damn
did the morning routine feeling great
very focused creative
now starting work right at 9am perfect
timing
today is going to be a good day i
usually always look forward to working
out
gives me a break from work and i can
listen to some podcasts some music
without any of that working out is
pretty boring
but i'm using the time to brainstorm
some ideas for new videos
[Music]
day two was miles better than the first
one and i wanted to take this week as an
opportunity to socialize more as well
where we going
a business networking pool party
epic the event was good met a couple of
interesting people
i definitely feel more relaxed than i
usually do especially at this time
around the day
so let's look at the other side of the
argument people saying it's
pseudoscience and just another fad and
after doing some research i found that
it's just incredibly misunderstood from
both sides
i watched multiple psychiatrists break
it down and i understood
everything perfectly which goes from the
ventral tag mental area
mesolimbic pathway dominates their
mesocortical pathway
i'll try my best first of all dopamine
detox the name is just misleading
it's no detox dopamine is not a toxin
it's a vital neurotransmitter the
dopamine levels actually don't change
the dopamine detox has nothing to do
with your dopamine level it has
everything to do with your dopamine
receptors
basically when too much dopamine is sent
through neurons the receptor the
receiving end
down regulates it to receive less is
that right
just let's go with it where now that my
dopamine receptors are kind of down
regulated
other activities let's say reading a
book going for a walk
start to feel less pleasurable so it's
not a dopamine
detox it's more like a dopamine receptor
reset and by the end of this video we're
gonna see if this whole thing had an
effect on my brain at all
the second misconception is that
dopamine is
actually not bad it's just misunderstood
man
it's responsible for your ability to
work hard have passion perseverance grit
set goals and go after them and we also
get dopamine from exercising
working on our business hugging someone
so dopamine isn't good or bad
it just depends on when it's being
released nature
come here therefore dopamine resets are
not about
cutting out all pleasure and you hear so
many people in articles and youtube
videos saying that
our brain is addicted to dopamine and it
wants dopamine but it's the other way
around
it's not that our brain wants dopamine
it's that dopamine
makes our brain want stuff and dopamine
is not really the pleasure molecule it's
the motivation molecule
it doesn't say i like it says i
want so whenever you feel the compulsion
to check your phone or you crave some
food
that's dopamine if you're compulsively
doing something
that you don't even enjoy you know it's
time for a dopamine reset
before going on this journey i asked a
bunch of you ambitious waiters if you
wanted to join me
for this adventure and some of you were
stupid enough to say yes why did you
decide to join for this
i've tried cutting it out so many times
guys get lost in it 15 30 minutes become
like one hour
two hours cryptocurrency to instagram to
snacking or
just scrolling have you noticed any uh
benefits so far or even on the first day
i noticed it totally more
more present i feel like i'm thinking
just talking to some of you
makes me realize how common this problem
is this little slot machine that we all
have
in our pockets and sometimes i wonder if
someone like shakespeare
grew up in today's time would he have
created all this great art
like just imagine the next shakespeare
the next elon musk
that have all these incredible
innovative ideas that would change the
world but instead of getting to work
they're hooked on tick-tock how many
great works of art and technology
are we missing out on because of
tick-tock the biggest
threat to my dreams coming true
me creating the thing that i want to
build a thriving community of people
that are weird and ambitious like us
the biggest threat is really social
media if i get too hooked on that thing
and i continue the way i have before
making this dopamine reset that ain't
gonna happen we're wasting our lives on
this [ __ ]
and who am i i'm preaching to the choir
i know that you know that otherwise you
wouldn't be watching this video
but why do we keep getting sucked into
it and what's the way out
for my work yesterday was listening to a
podcast he interviewed near a.l
his book indistractible is all about how
to remove a lot of these forces you
mentioned that only 10
of triggers are external so like
notifications
your boss 90 of the time we're
distracted because we're
uncomfortable with some sort of
sensation and we're looking for a
distraction from that boredom
loneliness fatigue uncertainty stress
how much of this
distraction is just because we don't
want to
deal with our emotions if distraction is
always there we can always avoid what
needs to be addressed and after time it
just bubbles up
more and more and that's why things like
anxiety are a rising issue not just
because it
makes you stressed while you consume it
but also because you never address
any of the emotions that are going
through your body what if it's just
about figuring out
what are we trying to avoid what are we
running away from and that's actually
what we
directly need to address for example i
mentioned mine multiple times which is
the feeling of loneliness
i don't know what you've been told we're
headed to the honor gym for a morning
workout
if you think you're gonna get away
playing small you're wrong
that's not what this place is about
ice bath gives you 250 dopamine
rush so dopamine is good when you're
getting it from healthy sources
now to some real talk though how do we
get back to normal life
because let's face it some of these
tools are incredibly valuable and if you
want to function in society you almost
got to be part of it but how can we use
only what we need as a tool and cut out
the things that are draining us
there are four things i'll be looking at
to fight against getting sucked into
internet rabbit holes number one
remove temptations don't have the apps
on your phone keep your phone locked
away from you and install apps like kill
newsfeed or distraction for youtube to
make the apps even on desktop really
really boring number two
define clear rules for example i could
say i keep my phone turned off until 1pm
i listen to only one podcast per day and
also always turning off my screen at 10
pm
and i also have an alarm set for that
and the hardest part number three
address the inner triggers i know it's
easier said than done but what is making
you want to get distracted is it
boredom is it discomfort is it
loneliness have some sort of mindfulness
practice to address these emotions
to deal with them in a healthy way it's
day six
we're nearing the end and i'm looking
forward to finishing this
[ __ ] these mortals so glued to their
phones
i can't relate i love you dopamine i've
always had strict rules around using
social media on my phone but
i want to adjust them a little bit to
really optimize them more
number one i want to continue reading
fiction in the evenings
because i think there's a good chance
that it would finally fix my sleep
issues that i've been having for years
so i ordered june which is a book by
frank herbert really looking forward to
that one secondly i want to continue
using a separate alarm that is not my
phone because then i can wake up without
touching my phone at all and in fact i
want to turn off the phone in the
evening
lock it in the closet and just leave it
there until the next day after my most
important work is done and on top of
that i want to proactively schedule time
when i'm going to be checking social
media and if i fall off just
continuing to get back on track again
this final day we spend all day
celebrating my friend's birthday in this
gorgeous place here in austin people
socializing sunshine
no phones it's beautiful a lot of fun
throughout these last few days i can
safely say that
i felt more present i felt more calm and
also the creativity has been slowly
coming back again
now i'm really curious to see if the
brain scan shows
any significant results here we are
after
seven days of dopamine resetting last
time i had
quite a few mistakes this time i was
super focused
and much more calm during the exercise
so now i hopped on a call with dr davis
brockenshire he's looked at
thousands of brain scans over the course
of his career and we'll look at the
reports to see what happened to my brain
this is your brain before the dopamine
distraction
we'll notice that the back of the brain
is very cold or very low voltage
you're putting out on average about 10
micro volts a little on the low end so
this is consistent with somebody that
has a lot of screen time
our sliding scale you can see you're
just tipping outside on the anxiety box
let's take a look at you after the fast
voltage one up
[Music]
not bad you've healed a huge part of the
back your brain
this is exciting because this is the
first time i'm seeing this as well
the reaction speed your brain got
quicker
look what we did here so you went into
this
on the verge of anxiety and you have
totally normalized your alpha waves
that's remarkable you can't do that in
seven days so well done
this is interesting there's no red your
brain is at peace
and i've never seen blue in theta but
this means your brain is extremely
efficient
at being calm it seems like this is the
way to go
wow that's awesome hey there i'm here to
give you more dopamine check out this
video here
i put a ton of work into all of them it
will not disappoint i'll see you over
there